We know that we want to find the inverse of B of t equals 1,000 e to the -.5t.
Which we know is going to be the reflection of that graph line y equals x. So,
that means we're looking for the equation this graph right here. This is B of t
and this is B inverse of t. Well let's think about how we might want to do
this. While we could divide both sides by 1000, and then maybe we could take
the t root, of both sides. That will get rid of the t on the right hand side,
in the exponent. But we would still have an exponent of t over here. since we
know that the t root is the same as taking this to the one over the t power. So
that's not going to help without that at all. We actually need a totally new
idea to solve this problem. And that ideas named by a Scottish mathematician
named John Napier discovered in 1614. His discovery was something called a
logarithm or just a log. We'll look at some simpler examples first log and then
come back to this example about bacteria once we have all the tools we need to
deal with it.